but the problem is that there's a Joker
in the pack there's a Joker in the pack
so these models even though they appear
to be doing exactly what I've just said
they're unreliable they're not
trustworthy and we don't understand how
they work they don't provide their
thinking or reasoning and there are some
clear cognitive capacities they clearly
don't still have like for example yeah
and and then I mean there's been calls
actually Melanie Mitchell spoke about
this in in her recent piece to have a
Manhattan Project of intense research on
ai's abilities limitations
trustworthiness and interpretability
where the investigation and results are
open to anyone
um what do you think about that was that
supposed to be sort of like transparency
she's saying well you know a prodigious
effort to understand what it is that
these models are actually doing because
the thing is if we have an over-reliance
on these models Society impacts to one
side
um we're now living in a world where we
lose all intelligible
Frameworks of understanding what the
[__] these things do
yeah and is that a problem yeah I mean I
don't understand how you think no that's
true so why why are you more reliable
well because either yeah I suppose that
that's not quite a straight
analogy is it because I even my greatest
capacity I'm very unlikely to have
influence over you and your day-to-day
life whereas AI will AI is far bigger
than any mind isn't it yes it's almost
like a metamine it's like it's it's much
much bigger and what I'm trying to say
is no I know no individual
mine's going to be likely to control you
unless you're in a sort of like
dictatorship but that's luckily it would
have probably not gonna be there for a
while I think the problem is the
pernicious enmeshment of this technology
in in society right it's it's ensconced
in our society it will be and that leads
to this erosion of autonomy and when so
many things you do day in day out are
controlled by this info sphere and this
is something which is deliberately
abstract we call it the infosphere but
you don't understand how it works no one
does and it just chips away chips away
chips away until in 10 years time you
don't have any control over what you're
doing yeah and the society frog isn't it
it's the slow boiling frog yeah no I and
I agree with that and I think important
that to be that to be that detached a
large number of people are that detached
from the
um even the basic understanding of the
things that are now dominating their
world so the only two groups that are
going to be interested in this although
those who can understand it and create
it and that's going to get smaller and
smaller and smaller as even they don't
understand it well okay can talk about
it intelligibly yeah to some degree they
can talk about it they can theorize new
ways come up with new ways of doing
stuff that might have a different result
because obviously that's been a
progression in AI it's not State static
is it and you can't unders always
understand where you're going to go with
it you can push it somewhere else and ah
find out what happens you know
um majority of people won't have the
capacity
to go beyond a certain line you know
everyone's gonna have a line somewhere
in it you know but as it becomes so
specialized it feels like the two groups
of people that are going to be running
the world or dictating this uh gonna be
controlling or describing or creating
that that that
um that enmeshment as as you um are
going to be those who technologically
can create it play around with it and
discover new possibilities within the
technology and those who can use it
effectively
to to to control yes you've got the
technical and the political sphere and I
think
the politicians or the political sphere
the bureaucrats are sort of who are
really good and with the desire to let's
be honest the problem we've left with
with bureaucrats and people who are high
up in politics they always want to
control more that's what makes them more
relevant that's what gives their life
more power and more more potentially
more eudemonium or self-actualization
I'm really good at telling other people
what to do yes that's my that's my thing
you know I can't possibly be happy and
as I'm telling everybody else how to
live their life but but cynically what
what better way to enslave people than
to truncate both their understanding and
their agency
yeah okay
so so which we're bringing up a new
Society of people like no one knows how
to use maps anymore but that didn't
really matter very much but now no one's
going to know how to think anymore yeah
it's such a good point Tim yeah yeah
it's okay when when cartography died it
wasn't the camera Humanity died yeah
exactly so one one was a form of
emancipation one was a form of
Oppression
um so it's now it's now becoming so much
and the problem is the way the info
sphere works is that there's no way to
live off the grid because even now if
you're a journalist if you're not using
large language models you are going to
fail as a journey because you're
competing against people that's it you
are using so not yet not only does our
Concepts change not as the function of
the world change the marketplace changes
yes yeah exactly and you're not and you
know you could be the clever guy the
funny guy the good artist of your
community and then of your village and
then if you're and then of your town or
your or your or your state or County 60
70 years ago and people would know
you're the guy who can draw really well
but now when it comes to social media
it's against the world yes and now
against machines yes yes but but also
that there's this pernicious
virtualization and abstraction of
everything so with generative Arts you
can now produce an abstract
image which is a confection a
confabulation of the work of thousands
of artists and when I produce this
YouTube video and we put it online it
will in the future be aggregated remixed
and confabulated into an infinitude of
streams of other content and you see how
it's not only my agency and
understanding it's also my personal
identity as being diffused in ways that
no one can currently understand yeah
which is and potentially that's not a
problem
well I it feels like it is a problem oh
no I yeah that's what I'm trying to say
is I think it is yeah there's an
argument because it's potentially it's
not
well I I think that this is a problem I
think what's not a problem is this
fictional
um you know recursive self-improving
intelligence I think I think the real
problem is the re-antologization of of
our society and the increasing
abstraction so already information is
the best way to understand the
functioning of our society yeah but when
you have information on top of
information on top of information it
becomes so abstract and divorced from
any intelligible understanding it just
becomes completely impossible for us to
do anything
um hmm and it's so funny take the first
um
uh what's the word he used speculative
danger the first one was about
misinformation yes now to me the term is
information is bizarre
because it implies
because to be honest it's only ever used
in this in the field of politics and
Society I mean you've got what I'm
saying it's not really misinformation
when it's in like a when it's in a small
little philosophical
um uh subject or or a technical subject
or misinformation you might be mistaken
and you get corrected
misinformation but misinformation is
nearly always talking about making a
large collection of people believe a
certain thing
well yes and we can distinguish
misinformation from disinformation so
the the malicious intent is important as
well still either yes either either from
what I'm talking about is a strange
thing because it implies or what it
keeps implies there is a table contents
of information there's a place where you
can get your information from yes that's
not miss or this yes and of course that
again helps centralized control which is
funny how he how he um could be is a
constant reference and and
encouraging individuals to believe there
is a there is a central Hub of
information they can go to which is
correct okay but what about the
industrialization of misinformation
because I often make the point that even
now
the world is full of things
always will be go and have a chat with
Bob down the pub yeah well Lucas what's
she gonna tell you exactly yeah yeah but
what I'm getting but do not think that's
a natural and that's
it's like what you have to accept if you
want any kind of freedom of thought you
have to accept that people can can
spread misinformation and disinformation
right but but I I would say the real
threat is not the misinformation per se
it's the effect on our cognitive
apparatus because increasingly we don't
need to do any work at all right
um Richard Dawkins always said that you
know when you bring children up they
should have an inquiring mind and a
healthy a healthy degree of skepticism
yes and increasingly we are just going
to become passive observers of
information we won't be directly
involved in discriminating information
yeah and then redefining it re making it
more precise more that's right I mean
when when you um enjoyable process yeah
when I when I plan um a tube journey
into London and I use Google Maps I'm
not interrogating it no I'm not saying
oh [__] I'm good
my friend yeah I can't believe they
didn't realize that you know so-and-so
station's got building works for the
next two you know you just you're
completely detached from it and you're
similarly going to be detached from
absolutely every form of information
and that's dangerous
okay so how how could that be prevented
prevented
well friends in lieu of understanding it
so the the two the two things that are
being eroded are agency and
understanding and in lieu of either you
you have this effect on society because
it means we've become a society of
automatons okay then is there anything
you think we could do to prevent it
wouldn't be worse than the uh outcome
well the the extreme version of this is
paternalism and which I think is which
is worse than the outcome probably
it's not about preventing the AI
as much as is the precedent that you'd
be setting what you can dictate to
individuals and Society
um you can't do that anymore
well the problem is the Technologies
become so democratized that anyone at
home
in their bedroom with a powerful machine
can start to build this technology so
you would have to basically say to
people that no you can't use your
computer anymore right and also you
would let China yeah you know so it's
it's very similar yeah it's very similar
to just trying to do all our best to
have a net zero policy in this country
by 2030 or 2050 it'll probably be
changed to about 2030. and then um that
will reduce it by one percent but we
just offset all of our carbon um
footprint to other countries yeah
they're not going to stop yeah so like
you said theoretically all it's doing is
putting us a major disadvantage yeah and
people hate people hate hearing that
because because it's been turned into
religion and I so an either or binary
isn't it Tim so either all binary either
a climate extremist
or your climate denier yes or alarmist
or denial there is no like you said
there's no saddle there's no there's no
point seven two everything's one or zero
um but what I'm getting could go back to
the misinformation thing or the so what
I'm saying you're saying that love by
approach wouldn't work anyway
because it's so democratized so in
ingrained into all the elements and
enmeshed into our day-to-day life it
could only be enforced with violence
right okay so it would be so we would
only be inviting fascism then yes so
therefore we can say that that isn't as
Superior a superior um outcome to
the explosion risk of the AI yeah see
what I mean yeah what are we concerned
about with the exposure of AI that we'll
lose our autonomy that will lose our
reason purpose and our freedom well
we're definitely going to lose it if we
go for the Luddite um way well the the
people who advocate for the explosion
that they are called doomers and they
they think one step further I mean many
of them accept that there will be these
societal near-term risks but they think
within 10 50 years there's an
existential threat so
um the AI will basically seek to kill
all of us
can can yeah so it's the question is can
a machine seek to do anything in that
respect
they they think so I mean this is
getting into you know can a machine have
intentionality can it will it will it
seek to deceive us will it seek to
preserve itself all I'm saying is we've
couldn't taking over Humanity as it were
that when the existential threat can
that be
could that as a intention be derived
through pure competent computation they
think so yeah yeah they think so
yeah what would be the but what would be
the virtue or the value to which it was
aimed for what I'm saying what would be
the differentiation between taking over
and not taking over how would the
machine or the AI just
discern one and Superior and on what
basis well that's that's the problem so
they say if you if you have a 10x
intelligence
um we can't understand it so we can't
understand what it thinks or white
things yeah okay and maybe we just know
when we're in handcuffs well yeah
exactly by the time we're in we're in
handcuffs it's too late yeah so a lot of
this is just based on this kind of
fanciful this is the straight Pandora's
Box thing isn't it yeah exactly it's
Pandora's Box